[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in this video we're going to be
discussing voldemort's loyal followers
the death eaters now in our own muggle
world there are both good
and bad people we have the morally
righteous on one side
pure selfless individuals that look out
for nothing but the best interest of
others
and on the other side we have
individuals that are fueled with hatred
who want nothing but pain and suffering
for the rest of humanity
most environments even outside the
context of civilizations
generally possess this type of dichotomy
a light and a dark
and the wizarding world is certainly no
exception in the late 1930s
1938 to be exact a young man by the name
of tom riddle began attending hogwarts
although on the outside riddle appeared
to be a normal young man
deep down he had an unimaginable number
of demons
demons that haunted him every single day
of his life
you see tom didn't have a normal
childhood as he was abandoned by his
witch mother
right at the time of his birth he didn't
have a mother or father figure
he was just left at an orphanage and so
he never had any true concept of love
or family like many powerful evil and
enigmatic figures of history riddle had
a rough start to his life
and this paved the way for the dark path
that he was destined to follow
but when riddle eventually began to act
on his dark nature
and began pursuing dark endeavors he
wasn't alone
and he was able to bring many other dark
witches and wizards along for the ride
while he was a student at hogwarts
riddle was a member of slytherin house
riddle's charismatic cunning and
manipulative nature
meant that it didn't take long for him
to form a gang of sorts
the gang that riddle formed was once
described by dumbledore as a
mixture of the weak seeking protection
the ambitious seeking glory
and the thugish seeking a leader who
could show the more refined cruelty
at that point in time riddle's gang were
known as the knights of all purges
a kind of sinister name derived from the
pagan holiday
or pergastnut a night when the devil was
abroad
the graves were opened and the dead came
forth and walked
when all evil things of earth and air
and water held revel
but if we fast forward to the year 1970
the beginning of tom riddle aka
voldemort's rise to power
these knights of walpurgis were known by
a different name
death eaters as far as dark witches and
wizards went
the death eaters were the worst their
group was comprised of evil witches and
wizards
that were all hell-bent on pursuing
their dark ambitions
they were the followers of lord
voldemort and they obeyed his bidding in
an effort to
cleanse the wizarding world with the
goal of restoring
pure blood authority over the wizarding
world the death eaters were a group of
pure blood radical supremacists
ever bloodthirsty and always more than
eager to resort to the darkest
of deeds if it meant achieving their
goal of blood purity
but one thing that i've always wondered
is how do witches and wizards get mixed
up with the death eaters
in the first place sure i suppose some
of them were there right from the start
as they attended school with riddle and
i suppose another portion of the death
eaters
came from the family lineage of the
original members but
what about the rest of them how do you
become a death eater
the first requirement to be an official
death eater is not only follow lord
voldemort
would also bear the dark mark a
fear-inspiring symbol
magically etched into the skin like a
tattoo the mark represents their goal of
cleansing the wizarding world
and is used by them as a way of inciting
fear in the general population
often projecting it into the sky using
the curse morse mort
then he realized that it was a colossal
skull composed of what looked like
emerald stars with a serpent protruding
from its mouth
like a tongue as they watched it rose
higher and higher
blazing in a haze of greenish smoke
etched against the black sky
like a new constellation arthur weasley
had a lot to say
about the symbol you know who and his
followers sent the dark mark into the
air whenever they killed
the terror it inspired you have no idea
you're too young
just picture coming home and finding the
dark mark hovering over your house
and knowing what you're about to find
inside everyone's worst fear
the very worst a distinction should be
made between the symbol that is
projected into the sky and the symbol on
their arm
however as the one in the sky is a
simplified version
of the one they bear on their arm which
is much more intricate
but who chooses who gets the dark mark
who gets to
officially decide who is a death eater
do they let in just anyone that's in
alignment with their cause
is it purely up to voldemort to decide
on new death eaters or can existing
death eaters
invite new wishes and wizards to their
group we know for sure that there's some
kind of recruitment process
in play because professor slughorn
mentions that the death eaters were
trying to recruit him
in the half-bird prince so all these
precautions against intruders
horus are they for the death eaters
benefits or mine
asked dumbledore what would the death
eaters want with a poor broken down old
buffer like me
demanded slughorn i imagine that they
would want you to turn your considerable
talents
to coercion torture and murder said
dumbledore
are you really telling me that they
haven't come recruiting yet slughorn
eyed dumbledore balefully for a moment
then muttered i haven't given them the
chance what this also tells me
is that slughorn is a target for
recruitment for a couple of reasons
first of all horus slughorn is a
pureblood wizard and that's probably the
most important aspect to consider when
bringing in someone new
a major goal of their cause is to
oppress smuggleborns
so bringing them on would be entirely
counterproductive
however we do know that they bring some
half bloods on board
like snape and i suspect that they would
only bring on a half blood
if they were particularly talented
magical talent can very easily translate
into sinister magical application and
that's probably the other main reason
that they targeted slughorn for he was a
truly powerful wizard
i have a couple of theories for how
death eaters are formally recruited
my first theory is that lord voldemort
handpicks all subjects himself
and simply sends his followers off to
retrieve them he's an incredibly
powerful wizard with the ability to read
people's minds
and i think that with all of his talents
he would be the best person to choose
his own followers
as he would be able to quickly figure
out if they were truly in allegiance
with him or not
it's also suggested by slughorn that
voldemort is involved with recruitment
as he mentions that he's most likely
involved bad books by avoiding him and i
suppose one could argue
that as i have not joined the death
eaters he who must not be named can
hardly count me a friend
in which case i might well be safer a
little closer to albus
so my first theory is basically this
voldemort makes an executive decision on
who he wants
and if they don't agree to his terms
they either join or die
my second theory involves voldemort's
existing followers
and a sort of death eater sponsorship
program which would allow death eaters
to bring on
new recruits vouching for them you would
be brought before lord voldemort
at which point he would analyze you
likely using legitimacy
to uncover your true intentions he would
then set you off on some kind of
initiation to prove to him that you are
worthy
what this initiation would involve is
not stated anywhere but i would imagine
that
similar to joining a gang it would
involve a hit or
sinister act of some sort the death
eaters are all huge proponents of the
unforgivable curses
so i would imagine that it would involve
them in some capacity
perhaps having to control torture or
kill someone
or maybe even a combination of the three
after successfully completing your
mission
you would then return to lord voldemort
and he would either approve or deny
your application if you weren't worthy i
expect he'd just kill you
and if you did prove your worth i
suspect that voldemort or one of the
existing death eaters
would come along and engrave the dark
mark on your arm
what do you guys think how do you
officially become a death eater
let me know down in the comments section
below until next time
you're a wizard harry
[Music]
you